With a population of over 30 million
people,
period,
the fourth biggest country in Latin
America,
one of the richest countries in the
world in terms of biodiversity and
natural resources in this vast in
country,
we can find among other things the
biggest silver reserves,
the third biggest zinc and copper
reserves,
as well as the sixth biggest gold
reserves in the world.
In today's video,
we're going to be talking all about Peru
equals youtube politic.
Now,
Peru is still ain't poor country and
there is still a lot of work to be done
when it comes to its industrial
framework,
but despite this,
Peru stands out among its Latin American
neighbors as an example of it.
Reforms done right and some say that if
this process continues,
we're soon going to be talking about
Peru as a great Latin American power.
Lima,
it's capital city already has a higher
GDP.
Even
economic
in the last decade has recorded the
second biggest growth rate of all
countries in Latin America in the same
period,
it's GDP has more than doubled.
The investment rate has gone from 13
percent of GDP to 20 percent under the
poverty rates.
This is the percentage of people who
can't afford basic things like food,
clothes,
education,
and healthcare has dropped from rates of
over 50 percent in the year,
2000 to 22 percent today.
This is a reduction of more than half,
which is not bad at all.
It's a country with the highest poverty
reduction rate in Latin America during
the last 13 years and say on top of all
that Peru is one of the least indebted
countries in Latin America.
Bands in fact is one of the least
indebted in the whole world.
This is due to a strong determination to
use public funds responsibly.
This is an achievement of perused
previous governments which were led by
Alan Garcia.
I'm Zella on polydor.
Because of these leaders,
the public debt has been reduced to less
than 50 percent since the year 2000.
That is still.
How did it reach a political consensus
that maintain stability with the
government's budget while also making
pro markets policy?
Yeah,
but one more and go being with them
now,
this is probably one of the most
interesting things about Peru and it's
also where they can see each other
countries even valuable lesson.
We recently made a video talking about
the disaster that is Venezuela,
but the interesting thing is that peruse
economic situation was pretty similar to
Venezuela's in the 19 eighties.
So let's have a look at what happened.
Eight,
these prices
in the 19 seventies and the beginning of
the 19 eighties,
the Peruvian government bets on boosting
the Peruvian economy,
fruit public investments,
they wanted to replace imports and to
restrict the sale of foreign products.
To achieve this,
they had to borrow money which shot up
the public debt.
The results were so bad,
the when the oil crisis happened in 1979
and their economic growth slowed down,
peruse government started to have so
many problems that in 1983 they had to
suspend their payments to their data's.
In other words,
they failed to pay their debts because
they ran out of money and the Peruvian
government collapsed.
From that moment,
things went from bad to worse,
and when Alan Garcia came to power in
1985,
the entire country was a bit of a
disaster.
This is when the government started to
intervene on a massive scale.
They started fixing prices and in the
labor markets,
they reinforced the inboard replacement
policies which are limited the number of
products that were available to buy and
setting an average tariff which reached
66 percent.
Okay.
The
public deficit went through the roof and
the informal economy became the norm,
so even though there were more than a
hundred taxes,
the state simply couldn't collect them,
and on top of all that,
the governments had collapsed,
so no one wanted to lend them money.
Now you might be wondering what exactly
did career do?
Well,
they started to print more money,
which basically made the [inaudible]
Berean currency worth about as much as
monopoly money,
as if all of that wasn't enough for
purview to deal with.
They also have to deal with the narco
traffic and terrorist actions by groups
such as Mrta and Sendero Luminoso,
which were causing tens of thousands of
deaths sold across the country because
we can throw in as soon as band does
inadequate.
Well,
what was the results of all this wild?
By the end of the decades,
GDP,
you had dropped by 25 percent.
Further its GDP per capita was similar
to the 19 sixties,
ends.
Inflation every year was about 7,500
percent.
It was at this point that the World Bank
recognized Peru as one of the poorest
countries in the world,
so you can throw them,
toby,
me receive,
but according to the situation was so
grave that the World Bank estimates that
if this had never happened for real GDP
and purchasing power parity,
would today be similar to Israelis,
Spain,
or South Korea's no more,
no less.
In many ways,
the crisis that Peru faced was very
similar to the crisis facing Venezuela
today.
For example,
you can see lots of public spending,
potency of taxes,
lots of printing money,
or dropping the price of commodities.
Oh,
and also plenty of violence,
so when we released our video about
Venezuela,
many people asked what we would do to
solve the problem.
Well,
let's have a look at what [inaudible]
did
way to prosperity.
90 a strong plan of reforms and economic
stabilization began and in fact this is
the same plan that really does still
exist today.
It passed through the following stages
in order to slow down inflation.
First of all,
the it was replaced by a new currency,
the new sole.
In addition to this,
the dollarization over the economy was
allowed,
which is essentially where US dollars
are used in place of a national currency
from vast moments.
Monetary stability in the country became
a national priority.
The tax system was changed and greatly
simplified with the elimination of 64
taxes.
Further,
the pension system was also reformed and
the Chilean system was used as a model,
but there were also many improvements
made.
This is actually quite a controversial
topic and something that we're going to
be addressing in a future of visual
politic videos like don't forget to
subscribe.
Further,
an ambitious program to attract
investors and privatized public
utilities was put into motion Syrian
companies such as Aero Peru,
Electra Lehman and the Peruvian
telephone company will put into private
hands a trade openness strategy was put
into place which reduced that
ridiculously high,
66 percent tariff to something closer to
one point five percent.
At the same time.
As this happened,
numerous free trade deals were signed,
including a very important ones with the
United States as well as the European
Union.
Then in 2002,
a gradual decentralization of power
started happening.
The result of this was that most public
investment spending today happens with
regions and municipalities,
and finally and probably the most
important points was their commitments
to budgetary stability.
This is something that since it was put
into place,
every government has respected.
It's talking about consequences.
It's actually in 1999 and law was put
into place called the fiscal
transparency and prudent snore.
This restricts the discretionary power
of governments to spend more than they
receive.
This includes correct developments for
public deficit situations.
Many experts on the subject contest.
This is one of the most important laws
in the history of Peru bus.
It's not all roses.
I don't think that we've forgotten the
dark side of this was the nineties.
Tell him his regime.
This was an authoritarian regime and the
president of it is now serving a 25 year
jail time.
He was convicted for crimes against
humanity and its corruption.
So it was important to keep in mind is
the situation that Venezuela faces today
is similar to the situation that
[inaudible] faced.
So keep in mind there's always a way out
today.
So now you might have in your mind the
question,
why is Peru still a poor country today?
As we said at the beginning of this
video,
the institutional shortfalls ends,
the challenges that faces today on many
among them.
We can't stress enough the high degree
of legal uncertainty and corruption.
This is something that we can definitely
see with the death squads case.
This is where under his regime from 2011
to 2015,
a group of policemen killed innocent
people for money.
Those guilds included a general and a
major firm peruse national police
further are extremely high levels of
crime and there's also the chance that
the mining industry will face the same
Renzi,
a problems that one faces today.
Not to mention,
there is a very sharp difference between
the living standards in different
regions.
On the fifth of June,
2016,
the second rounds of presidential
elections were held where Pedro Pablo
Kaczynski was elected as the new
president of the Republic of Peru.
These elections were the closest in
peruse history and cruises.
Inscape beat out his rival Keiko for him
Maury,
who by the way is Alberto.
For him or his daughter,
he beats her by just 40,000 votes.
The policies announced buying Kaczynski
include to keep working on the agenda of
pushing competitiveness and trade
openness.
In this regard.
He has pledged to reduce taxes by 10
percent.
The smes that small or medium sized
enterprises as well as battle against
bureaucracy remove unnecessary
regulations and to pursue regional
economic integrations similar to the TPP
or RCP led by teachers,
ski against to remain at the helmet
financial,
all of the problems that are affecting
Peru despite his relative political
weakness because they're not very
friendly congress,
I'm sure that the grief of Peru will
continue and will remain a leader in
growth for Latin America and maybe in a
few years.
Peru,
which is a young nation with an average
age of 27,
could follow the example of the Asian
tigers and it gets transformed into a
major global power.
So that is our opinion here.
Revisional visual politic,
and we would love to know what you
think.
We'll be able to leave poverty behind
and become an economic powerhouse and
his Kosinski the ideal person to achieve
this.
Let us know your opinion in the comments
below and we'll see.
If you did like this video.
Please do hit that like button below and
don't forget,
subscribe for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday and I'll see you
next time.
Or as they say and catch why to Panama
cheeks.